[Music]
[Music]
oh that's all crazy wow what a freaking
summer I have had okay today guys I just
want to fill you in on my summer and how
it was being a videographer intern I
feel massively massively lucky to have
had this opportunity because I guess the
word internship always comes with
worries of is it gonna be unpaid or and
they're gonna just be making coffee or
am I actually man learn things and I
think this was the best internship I
could have ever wished for not only did
I get to learn new skills from how to
handle cameras and different equipments
like sliders I also learned how to be a
better presenter how to sit in front
people that I've never met before and
ask some questions and engage them in an
interesting way that would make an
interesting video an interesting
documentary an interesting interview
with those people because oddly enough
that seems to be what I'm innately good
at I think I don't know but it's helping
me understand a bit more about myself
what I'm good at in this field I know I
love video I know I love storytelling
you know love all this stuff you know
but working in a company for three
months and doing editing filming and
being on camera it's helping me to
understand how I request an individual
and how I might work best in a team as
well before I start rambling on about
how this internship changed me and
developed my content and made me more
confident as a person I will show you
some clips from the three months that I
spent throughout my videography
internship natural
is you working a qsr love in your time
here and editing footage of yourself are
you working on their yaks and worst
insurance to that yes or no
hey guys so I am in malmö but I can't be
having you seeing my hotel room like
this because I have been invited for
business this is my first business trip
so I don't really know how much of this
I'm actually gonna film cuz I will be
working but I want to share it with you
because this is my first it's my first
proper I don't know business holiday
[Music]
fancy seeing you here
I feel like I'm in a commercial for aloe
vera original it's so tasty I should
have probably pulled myself a glass
rhino so do have one and that'll be more
sophisticated with this mmm I just went
at my eye I'm in Sweden okay okay so
since I had this videographer internship
opportunity it has been probably one of
the best things in my life so far
I think I finally found a job where I
feel like I can maybe do well I don't
know I'm just surrounded by people who
make me feel confident and they trusted
me and I trusted myself because of it
and it's really nice so they have
decided to fly me out to Sweden to film
one of their conferences along with Kai
so what's happening Yankees what we do
what we're doing where are we we're
waiting to film wait do they even know
where you are what you're doing any guys
this is Kai from Kai creative and today
we are in Malmo Sweden and we are
filming the move the move on conference
keep saying that I'm like padawan
because I'm the intern and he's the
actual videographer but he just says
that we're on the same level this is
what I mean there everyone is just so
lovely and you know just really
supportive of everyone else and how is
your internship going very well really
well it's that I feel like you have to
say that because you know Horomia
I cry every night it's a painful
experience it's very tiring I'm learning
a lot and I'm feel really confident
actually it's boosted my self-esteem
good would you have changed your mind
from the beginning if he knew it was
gonna be like this which you decided not
to do how long I mean what no I would do
no no I wouldn't have changed her mind
this is better than I thought it was
gonna be like everything's perfect my
house is perfect in London the
internships perfect I'm in Sweden what
more could you want
what do you think of Sweden oh I love it
I love that people bike everywhere
because people do that in in London a
very weird angle people do that in
London but there's no proper bike things
nice little bike things here bike lanes
and people were in like in the little
kayaks just like kayaking down the
canals so you say that what are your
hopes this is my V do do this is my view
dude I don't know whether cutting mr.
doodoo it's not very good do you do so
of course I got to do all of the the
basic videography things and that was
great I knew a lot more about
composition a lot more about camera
settings and lot more about the small
things that I didn't even think about
before and I'm so happy because in my
latest videos I have had comments me you
guys saying oh you're editing is going
so much better or the quality has gotten
so much better and I'm like yes but I
can tell that from this three-month
internship it's made such a difference
even just of the videos that I'm doing
now so like it's good but I mean as well
as being taught all of this videography
stuff and being flown out to Sweden and
being asked to film conferences and
interview clients and everything else I
was also given the creative freedom to
dictate how to run a YouTube channel oh
I should say help dictate because of
course it's already being run
but they just needed a fresh face to
come in and kind of tell them what new
ideas they should maybe try out and it
was great I got to have my own film room
and just kind of go haywire and make a
stop-motion suit Casey thing and come up
with less than this a list of ideas and
oh my gosh it was just so so much fun
and then also obviously after having
made those ideas that had to think about
it in a more business sense instead of
just like oh the viewer will enjoy this
which is what I do for this channel I
had to think why is this video relevant
to the company how is it relevant to its
mission and its values how is it gonna
bring in this target audience that they
haven't managed to bring in yet and just
think about it kind of more logically
and statistically that's really raised
my understanding of YouTube as a
platform which just made me think
differently about this channel as well
and has actually led me to believe that
I should be working very hard on two
different platforms one for me which
will be this one and one with a more
business mindset just like what I was
doing
throughout my internship because
unfortunately YouTube's algorithm is a
thing and however great your content is
you have to be playing towards that
algorithm and sometimes that can be a
bit stressful so if you're doing it just
for fun it can just be a bit too much
but if you're doing in a business sense
you can make it work and that's
something that I want to carry on doing
for myself there's more there's more I
was just so lucky to be surrounded by
people who actually just trusted me they
just had confidence in me as a person
and what I could do for them and and my
knowledge of YouTube with the platform
and the audience that that are
surrounded by it so because of this if I
ever kind of had a crazy idea which it's
very much like me I'll just kind of
babble and I don't expect anyone to
actually listen because I'm just kind of
rambling what's going on my head they
would listen and they would take note
that was really really lovely of them I
don't know if I should tell you all
these things
maybe I'll cut those bits out but I just
wanted to say thank you to everyone who
believed in me and that's not just the
people who I worked with and it was
amazing to work with them it was
comforting cook us but it's also to to
you guys to my friends to my family to
everyone who sees how much hard work I
put into my videos in this channel and I
see a lot of comments saying you know
why don't you have more views and this
and that and that it just shows that if
you really put a lot of time and effort
into what you're doing and you love it
and you're passionate about it and that
shows doesn't matter about the numbers
or how big you are or anything like that
keep doing what you're doing because
people will notice if you do put all
that effort in and you are passionate
about it when you speak about it and
you're constantly trying to better
yourself and whatever you're making
whatever you're doing people are going
to notice you you're gonna get given
opportunities very much like the one
that I've just been given it could
change everything if I can do it and
don't forget I'm still a relatively
small youtuber and everything else and
you can do that too if I can do it you
can bloody do it too okay I'm sorry if I
ended up rambling there I'm just very
excited and I just wanted to share with
you my amazing summer and all the clips
and everything that I'd taken from the
three months of being there I know this
is gonna help me to no end
I am already ten fold more confident
bloody hell this white van has just come
my face is blown up but look at me I am
glowing I am so confident and just
having people believe in you makes all
the difference all the difference so I
just want to say thank you to everyone
watching everyone who sends me wonderful
comments everyone who who supports what
I do who believes in me and thank you to
Thai creative for mainly pointing up my
YouTube channel to the company that gave
me the internship thanks thanks thank
you you don't understand what you've
done for my confidence levels they are
through the roof another massive thank
you is to my patreon throughout this
summer I have been living in London and
it has been difficult and you guys
your support and helping me the very
best way that you can has really frickin
help me that's all I could say it's
helped me so much because living in
London is it's very difficult sometimes
that throughout my three months knowing
that you guys there for your support it
really really helped me and I don't know
why I've got stutter but like a really
really help me
I've set up a discord chat just for the
page for yo nays and it's great because
we chat every now and then it's really
good I'm gonna open up another disc or
chat in the future for yog man acts as a
community that I won't really be as much
involved in but if you want to be part
of that patreon disco chat all you have
to do is be a patreon thank you for
everything it's been awesome oh and last
little thing if you wanted to buy some
merch I feel like I'm just selling
myself here but if you like my drawings
I know a lot of you follow what I do on
Instagram and Twitter that I have
started to sell my drawings on different
things like mugs and t-shirts and phone
cases and even pillows so if you want
that if you want that little picture of
the YAG man with our hair all crazy you
can buy that now so do check out the
links in the description below
and yeah enjoy if you wanna you don't
have to but just totally up to you
anyway I'm gonna leave it there I hope
you enjoyed this footage from my
internship if you have any more
questions about it do let me know in the
comments below and have a lovely day or
evening bye